[Music]
address
what's that a safe house in paris why
would i need a safe house in paris
should things at some point go
terribly wrong it's good to have a place
to go you know
for a cup of tea my brothers
my sisters the clock is ticking faster
my dream we who live
for truth for love
the moment has come to take our rightful
place
in the world where we wizards
were free
join me
or die the wizarding and non-wizarding
worlds have been at peace for over a
century
grindelwald wants to see that piece
destroyed
you want me to hunt him down
to kill him
[Music]
dumbledore why can't you go i cannot
move against grindelwald
it has to be you
you don't suffer from motion sickness
see i don't do well on boats
you'll be fine
do you know why i admire you nick you do
not seek power
you simply ask is the thing right
the time's coming when you're gonna have
to pick a side
[Music]
no i don't do sites what are you gonna
do
i think there's something mute
you never met a monster you couldn't
love let's take him
that's your brother
i think that might have been the best
period of my life